que ce soit l'anxiété ou les symptômes
de dépression majeure des troubles
psychologiques affectent une personne
sur cinq dans le grand montréal
on sent que c'est différent on crie on
veut pas s'approcher des autres il ya
des gens qui sont venus et dames console
ces gens là c'est plus porter un appât
nick et ses valeureux donc être menée
début septembre par l'université de
sherbrooke dresse un portrait du niveau
de détresse des québécois face à la
pandémie
au delà du virus ce qui est vraiment un
deuxième membre de choc que sont le
l'anxiété la dépression sans et au sein
de la population québécoise et ses
troubles frappe surtout les jeunes
pourtant on n'a pas accès à notre
famille on a mis sous toit qui doivent
arrêter de travailler je pense que tu as
encore pays je pense pas que s'étonner
c'est pas normal qu'on en arrive là mais
c'est normal que ce soit le résultat
qu'on vit actuellement près de 40 % des
18-24 ans présentent des symptômes
d'anxiété ou de dépression majeure 410
c'est presque inimaginable je le dis de
la misère à le croire et pourtant c'est
ce que les chiffres réels et ça c'est
vrai à l'échelle des sept régions qui
ont examiné le niveau de détresse des
québécois est comparable à celui vécu
par les gens de fortes mcmurry après des
violents incendies qui ont ravagé la
région
quand on voit à quel point les impacts
sont majeurs de la pandémie à l'échelle
du québec
un état d'esprit que le passage en zone
rouge et les nouvelles restrictions
pourraient bien exacerbée ici vincent
maisonneuve radio canada montréal